ومن التورت في الفساد الى التورط يا
عسكريا اقليم كردستان تحاول فيه طهران
صارفا الانتباه الغربيه عن الاحتجاجات
الداخليه والسيناريو هو اشتياح بري كما
هدد القاده العسكريون الايرانيون وهذه هي
حدود العراق مع ايران وهذه هي حدود اقليم
كردستان العراق مع ايران تشهد تحركات
عسكريه ايرانيه كبيره قوات كبيره للحرس
الثوري واليات عسكريه ثقيله ودبابات
متاهله على الحدود والحرس الثوري حشد قوته
هنا في ماريوان وسارداشته وبانا ونغدى
وبيرا شهر وشنو في المقابله مشاهده هنا
ايضا توسيعه مقررات الاحزاب الكرديه
الايرانيه في مناطق الاقليم وهي اهداف
ايرانيات استهدف الحارس بعضها بالصواريخ
الانتحاريه واشد الهجمات كانت على معسكرين
الى الدولي لكن ان نفذت ايران تحديداتها
من اين ستدخل قواتها
بحسب خبراء عسكريين فان من المحتمل ان
تتقدم القوات الحرس الثوري من مناطق رخوه
امنيه السليمانيه مثلا ومن المحتمل ان
يكون الهجوم اعلى في منطقه زرقاويس وحيث
هنا مقر حزب كوملاء الكردي الايراني
محتمله في السليمانيه يمكن ان تكون في
باشماخ وسيران بينا وبراويز خان وهي منافذ
حدوديه بين العراق وايران وتعد ايضا مناطق
اخوه امنيه نحولا اخر وهو محور اربيل من
قضائيه كويسه
ايرانيا لمقاره تابعه لاحزاب كرديه معارضه
خيارا اخر مدينه حاج عمران
يمكن ان تكون من المناطق المستهدفه كذلك
بحسب المعطيات على الارض فان تهديد قائد
الحرس الثوري الايراني اسماعيل قراني
للقادات العراقيين بالاجتياح البري خيارا
قائما وحقيقيا كون المصادر تفيد بتحشد
القوات من الحرس الثوري الايراني على
الشريط الحدودي مع العراق بمسافه تصل الى
120 كيلومتر ضمن ثلاث مناطق ايرانيه وهي
سرداش بيرشار واشنويا والتي تقابل مدنا
بمحافظه
السليمانيه وهم شومان
وقلعه جزاء لعزل كردستاني ايران عن
كردستان العراق ومحاوله منهم لاجهاض
الاحتجاجات الايرانيه في كردستان ايراني
تحديدا الا ان قرار بغداد بنشر قواتنا من
حرس الحدود العراقي على الشريط الحدودي في
المناطق المذكوره وكذلك مع تركيا قد يساهم
بشكل او باخر من ايقافه فرضيه الهجوم
المحتمله البري الايراني على الاراضي
العراقيه